it's great to welcome to the program
today jeffrey kane senior fellow in
critical emerging technologies at the
lincoln policy network and also author
of the book the perfect police state an
undercover odyssey into china's
terrifying surveillance dystopia of the
future a book i recently read uh great
to have you on today i really appreciate
it thanks for having me david so
i i for people who
maybe have not studied this topic or
have only a kind of passing or a
rudimentary understanding of what has
been going on in china in particular
with the with the uyghur population
maybe we can back up a little and ask
the question
what have relations been between the
chinese communist party and the uyghur
population particularly in xinjiang
historically in china
uh yes so
uh so xinjiang is a region of china
that's about twice the size of texas and
it's on you could say the western
frontier of what is today china but
historically it was home to a group of
people called the uyghurs um who are
mostly muslim
and they populated this region for
for hundreds almost a thousand years
uh this is this is really their homeland
uh i think a good comparison would be to
imagine
uh you know the the european settlers in
america and the native americans and
that's sort of how china looks at this
region it's a place that it's been
expanding westward into and it keeps
running into this uighur population and
these other ethnic minority groups who
practice a different religion have a
distinct language a distinct culture
there are about 12 million people there
um sparsely populated area it's it's
oasis and deserts and mountains and it
truly is the place that china has been
trying to build and develop with oil and
railroads and you know turning it into
this frontier land where uh chinese
settlers can can go and they can find
their riches of opportunity
so in i mean in terms of the motivations
for for the treatment of the uyghur
population to be what it is
there are
you know
perspectives that say this is mostly
xenophobic lines based on muslim
religion there are other perspectives
that say there's a sort of business
oriented perspective as you're talking
about and desires to turn that area into
something that is much more financially
viable what is the origin of the
circumstances as we now see them
so uh there's a lot of origins to the
situation in xinjiang
there are currently about 1.8 million
people in concentration camps in this
region which is about one-tenth of the
minority population so you know imagine
the uh you know the the north american
equivalent it's as if a minority blacks
or or native americans or whoever it
might be
one-tenth of them being taken away
without being charged with a crime to a
concentration camp the reasons for this
uh many reasons
but it mostly goes back to
you could say a war on terror just taken
to an extreme um you know that the us
was waging the war on terror for many
years it's calmed down now but china
seized on that war on terror and took it
to an
authoritarian uh system over these
people
uh you know that the
state that they're affected terrorist
ideas that they need to be purged and so
they created this total surveillance
dystopia using artificial intelligence
and overhanded policing and facial
recognition cameras everywhere to to try
to get inside the thoughts of every
single leaguer to predict their behavior
and to try to turn them into good
patriots of the state
okay so you mentioned the facial
recognition in the book you talk about a
lot of the different sort of elements of
the surveillance state that are in place
there kind of a two-part question can
you talk about some of the other
surveillance methods that that are used
and also are these
only in place in this region or are
these also to some degree
in other parts of china as well
so when i was writing the book it was
starting shinjang these measures were
being rolled out in the region and they
were experimental about four years when
i started writing the book since i've
published it these methods these tactics
and technologies have expanded
uh throughout many parts of china so
tibet great great example inner mongolia
there are all these regions of china
that are home to minorities that are who
are being repressed violently um so to
give you an idea of other tactics um
just imagine
an old sci-fi novel or a movie i think
that this is most like the movie
minority report with tom cruise about a
police force that tries to engage in
predictive policing they can try to
predict a murder and then arrest the
person and brainwash them they brainwash
them in this system before the murder
can happen
that's what's happening
data points and the data points could be
things like you know whether a person
leaves the home the front door at 5am
every day go to work whether they go
grocery shopping you know uh every other
day at 6 p.m what do they buy there are
cameras watching them what do they read
in the case of my book i found one young
woman
in too many books
and there is a
you know there are these camera systems
everywhere that are watching you and
gathering this data and then trying to
predict
are you going to be a threat to the
state in the future are you going to try
and commit some kind of terrorist
rebellious act against the communist
party and so they take you to a
concentration camp psychologically
physically torture you and try to get
you to resent your supposed evil ways
and to become this the shell of your
former self where you simply accept and
internalize the demands of the communist
party now in the book you you describe
kind of two different layers there's the
re-education camps
and what are sometimes called the
concentration camps and the
concentration camps are worse than the
re-education camps it seems that
typically there's more of an exit path
from the re-education camps if you sort
of comply and are you know do it doing
what you're asked it can you talk about
the relationship between these two kind
of levels that exist there
certainly so there are more levels now
the system has expanded since i wrote
the book um so the lowest level is just
i mean they call it a re-education
center um the formal name is
re-education and training center and
this is a place where you'll be summoned
there as a uyghur person
to undergo you know patriotic lessons to
study law and civics and all that sort
of thing
and then after you you know show you
might go for like two years for a class
and you can go home every day maybe at 6
pm to see your family or maybe go home
for the weekends but you have to stay
there a certain amount of time um that's
the that's one of the lower levels
if you're deemed a more serious threat
then you're kicked up to what is called
a detention center
and a detention center is just a
euphemism for a full fully loaded
concentration camp that's where they
have the guard dogs and the swat teams
and the the guard posts and you know
snipers up there watching everyone um
these places are truly terrifying i
haven't been able to personally visit
one and obviously it wouldn't be you
know something you can just drop in and
you know report on gather information on
but
i was able to gather i interviewed more
than a hundred uyghurs who had been
through these camps who had managed to
get out you know through various means
uh and just the stories they told were
absolutely terrifying i mean this is
uh this is something different
altogether from the atrocities that we
saw in the 20th century uh the 20th
century was the age of genocide it was
the age of the uh you know the the big
camps where they had mass graves of
auschwitz of the khmer rouge and
cambodia um you know the the mass the
mass killings of of men women and
children
um you know that that was truly a
terrifying time to be alive in a lot of
places uh when it comes to xinjiang and
china in you know in the 21st century
and in the year 2022 now we're seeing um
the evolution of new forms of mass
surveillance and mass atrocities the the
chinese nation the government has
perfected ways of controlling people of
finding ways to
control their identity to try to
brainwash them into being someone else
without actually outright you know
killing them they don't pull out a gun
and shoot you and put you in a mass
grave they don't have a gas chamber they
they manage to erase your identity erase
your culture and to essentially commit
genocide through that through the use of
overhanded technology
so
there is a movement that
oh man it's like hard to even know how
to do this justice in in bringing up
there are some who are increasingly
denying
to different degrees that this is even
taking place now there are some who say
it's it's not a genocide they don't
necessarily deny
some elements of what you're saying but
you're saying people aren't really being
wholesale killed that part's not going
on although what's going on isn't good
there's others who are making claims
like the messengers presumably some of
the people you spoke to
are people who are making up these
stories to either attack the chinese
communist party because they are
anti-anti-communist or whatever
i don't want to re too narrowly
characterize where this comes from but
in the us it does seem to be folks who
generally speaking are
more sympathetic to not only the chinese
communist party but to the politics of
the hugo chavez maduro type regimes in
venezuela it's that there seems to be
sort of like a a a in being in league
there
i can't adjudicate every single claim
but can you talk a little bit about the
origins of this and whether there's any
aspect of it that requ we should be
paying attention to specifically
oh yes so uh we know uh without any
doubt whatsoever by now that these
atrocities are happening that the camps
exist we have a full documentation we
have satellite imagery
we have thousands upon thousands of
testimony from refugees many of which
line up in my case i interviewed 168
people including not just refugees but
people who were inside the system who
actually worked for the chinese
technology companies building these
systems uh you know i i mean we went
through chinese corporate records even
chinese companies that build these
systems they like to brag they're proud
of what they do they don't see it as
something shameful or worth hiding you
know they've admitted to it openly in
the chinese language if you can read
mandarin you can find corporate reports
that talk about what they're doing in
xinjiang there isn't
you know there there are no secrets
anymore to what's going on and it's
really unfortunate that um you know in
the states in particular or just in the
western world um you know there are
people um they tend to be more on the
left on the hard left who um you know
they they think that um you have to
choose the reasoning goes that you have
to choose one or the other if you side
with the united states of america then
you are an imperialist colonialist uh
bastard who's just trying to oppress
china trying to oppress you know global
non-aligned uh you know people of color
movements that's sort of how they frame
it so therefore the idea you should be
sympathetic to china and see these you
know these accusations of genocide these
camps therefore they must be made up by
this you know this american imperialist
system these evil conservatives are just
making up stuff to smear china to
justify a war against china uh you know
that's it's just um you know it's
outright denialism and it's really
unfortunate that some of the these these
sort of these leftists these hard
leftists and socialists
who claim to uphold progressive values
you know at home they talk about social
justice and then when it comes to you
know minorities overseas and other
countries they're on the side of an
authoritarian regime so the term tanki
and it just so i i don't know if you've
heard that term tanky but yeah i've said
before i fi because it has such a
pejorative uh connotation i tend to call
it the revolutionary left and this is
someone on the left who considers myself
a progressive i've chosen that term but
certainly tanky's the term i'm familiar
with
yeah yeah and um you know i would
consider myself kind of a progressive
centrist you know i support human rights
around the world uh you know there are
also people on the other side to you on
the right who uh you know just have
these crazy crazy views about uh you
know the tr the chinese global
conspiracy taking over the world so um
you know it's uh it's unfortunate that
this particular topic gets polarized uh
when there are major human rights
atrocities uh happening
what about more specific so that's that
gives us a great kind of general
orientation what about the more narrow
claim that a lot of what is being
described is absolutely happening you
can't deny the surveillance the
satellite surveillance all that but that
there is not genocide taking place
so the genocide question is a step
question
and that falls under the international
law of
genocide um so so
so here's the thing about the genocide
question
the
one of the major problems that needs to
be one of the things that needs to be
established is the intent to commit
genocide chinese officials
defend themselves by arguing
that they are not committing genocide
they are simply developing the region
there they claim that they're trying to
lessen birth rates they don't want you
know they want family planning
uh and when they defend themselves that
way that places these projects in a
different kind of framework and that's
what makes it more difficult to prove
that this is actually a genocide now
under international law the one major
factor that would make this a genocide
that numerous academics and scholars
have documented well is the forced
sterilization
of women the forced sterilization
uh in an attempt to erase uh an entire
people to erase the next um generation
it's uh and that is really you know i
think that if there's gonna be that one
uh you know kind of that one turning
point within international law that one
thing um that's going to be the thing
that will define this as genocide in the
future
uh the book is the perfect police state
we've been speaking with the author
jeffrey kane i so appreciate your time
today and and really uh recommend the
book to to anybody who's interested in
this topic or isn't yet interested but
but really should be uh really
appreciate your time thanks david